hello everyone welcome to a brand new
episode of the witching hour we're just
gonna get right to it
you know me I'm Perry you know Haley
believed a very special guest in studio
right now we have bright burn director
David Yarra vests key okay thank you
congratulations thank you so much so
right off the bat you guys should know
that we have seen bright burn we have
given two thumbs up to break nice to
hear congratulations to you thank you so
we kind of want to start with the
beginning right now and get a little
because you have an interesting
background in an interesting resume that
isn't necessarily oh one feature film
then move on to the next you have some
shorts and you have some different
content on your resumes so I don't know
I guess day one how'd you get into
filmmaking period you know I'll tell you
a story that I don't often tell because
you know people won't find it as cool as
I found it and it didn't have you know
it doesn't kind of like resonate it
doesn't resonate with a lot of audience
there's a lot of audiences I could just
say hey I you know made music videos and
then I started making movies and
everyone will be like cool but but
you're teeing up this story in a
fascinating way too you're gonna dig it
but for like a horror audience I think
they'd be a little excited about this
portion of the story I guess so when I
was really young I was I I thought I
want to do like makeup and special
effects I mean really young right like
like like seven eight nine well you know
like in that age and and so I had my
dad's camera and I'd like to tall these
things and I'd like set up the camera
and fit plan all these shots and then do
like you know my best attempt at tenets
like a special effect and my dad makes
teeth
he owns a dental laboratory and he makes
teeth for
to be aware of the dentist oh really I
have to go to the dentist this week and
I'm so upset
I'm sure he won't rip any of you I hear
the word drill and automatically I start
to cringe oh yeah sorry so so so he
makes teeth and for 99 percent of his
work that means he just makes teeth for
dentist and you know it's a it's a
pretty normal non entertainment job but
but he he got contacted by Rick Baker
wants to to work on something I don't
know what it was I don't think it ever
actually happened but they talked about
you know doing something like he needed
some kind of teeth things that work kind
of beyond his capacity and so and so my
dad was like oh my son is a huge fan of
yours can he come into the shop and I
think I was 14 or 15 at the time maybe
younger maybe 13 and he said sure so I
came in I got like a total tour of of
Rick Baker studios in 1992 or three or
so you know like way way early on I mean
I guess it's not really on his career
but just a long time ago you know when
when there was a lot of really cool
stuff you know the American Werewolf in
London mmm stuff here and you know
really cool stuff and and I met him I
talked to him I begged him to let me
like sweep up around the shop or
something cuz I had read that like
that's how he started to start working
for dick Smith and like swept up around
the shop and so I begged him to let me
do that and he was like you are too
young and there are laws and that I just
cannot have you in in a in a place where
there's toxic chemicals and you know but
he was like good luck and and then he
said if you if you're serious about
doing makeup special effects you should
go to dick Smith's school for special
effects and I was like what is dick
Smith school for special effects I will
definitely do that so he they gave me a
phone number he gave me a phone number
and I I was like wow thanks and I left
and I was so intimidated to call dick
Smith's makeup school I don't know it
just seemed scary it seemed like me like
like talking to real people who do
things so so I was scared and so I
waited a couple weeks until I grew grew
that the nerve to call and then
I and and then I waited for a Sunday and
it was like a Sunday morning and I
called so that I would definitely get an
answering machine and just leave a
message and I called and a woman
immediately answered and was like hello
and I said oh I'm calling for dick
Smith's makeup school maybe I have the
wrong number and she's like oh hang on
dick and he clearly liked his home line
and he gets on the phone and he talked
to me for maybe 45 minutes and and and
and if you think about like the idea
that some guy picks up the phone you
know dick Smith makeup artist legend
picks up the phone and talks to a 13
year old 14 year old kid for 45 minutes
about what his dream is you know and and
and throughout the conversation he
started asking me why I want to do it I
told him I really liked setting up the
shots I plan I'm making these boards and
then I shoot him and stuff and he's like
man you're not a makeup artist you're
you're a director and I was like oh well
yeah I guess he's like well you like
telling the story and you're like
putting all the pieces together and I
was like yeah and and and he was like
yeah you're you were not a makeup are
you know if you called me and told me
you like sculpting all day you're a
makeup artist yet but he's like that's
not what you said you your director go
be a director and so and so I guess I
did so so yeah that was kind of like a
game-changing moment for me in my life
and it was it was surreal and it was
crazy and you know like you know over
the course of you know I'm 39 years old
now so so the the the journey to get
from you know a ten-year-old who wants
to make movies scary movies to now
there's all these little stories along
the way that are cool but that one to me
at least it really stands out to me but
only the SIRT the right audiences will
love it as much as I do you know what I
mean like if I if if you know I don't
know if a more broad publication you're
talking to the right crowd absolutely
did not explain who he is or why it's
important to me that he told me to go be
a director you know and so and so yeah
anyways that was kind of my start and
then and then yeah I mean then I went on
made stuff and and I I started raising
money to make to make stuff really young
and and I mean I don't know I could talk
about this for a long journey to this
seat right here
that's a it's an hour-long podcast alone
did you did you take the film school
track or did you go straight into making
things and okay circumvent okay you want
the other story yeah you want the other
story to me because I think if someone
jumps in it can work for them but also
it's totally possible to build a career
without that too so it's like you can't
really necessarily say this is what you
should do well that's 100% true and
there are times true like I did not go
to film school okay and I'll tell you
one more kind of really fun horror story
moment that I had that kind of you
already set a pretty high bar and but
but I didn't go to film school and there
were times over the journey where I was
not where I wanted to be in my life
where I looked back and thought would it
have been easier for me if I went to
film school and the answer is yes
probably like it probably would have
been an easier journey but at the same
time I don't think I would have been as
well equipped to take on the projects
you know like you know when I was 24 I
was really close to making a movie and
and I was really bummed that it didn't
happen and then when I was 34 I made my
first movie the hive and and at that
time when I finished it I said thank God
the movie when I was 24 it didn't happen
because I was just not at all ready or
prepared for what making a movie for
half a million dollars would feel like
or be like or just
I just a level of I don't know the the
complications that come with it you know
but anyways I'll tell you the story that
I know you like and I'll tell it quickly
because I feel like I'm dominating when
I was when I was debating whether or not
I would stay in school I was in like a
junior college I was never good in
school right it was just like fail
barely didn't fail out of high school
and then and then the same thing with
college I was not doing well and and I
was debating whether or not I would stay
or I would go on to work on other things
and I started raising money to make this
stupid little cartoon and like the Troma
offices gave me their offices to like
throw a fundraiser at and and that night
I am I pulled in early III like to show
up early and like be prepared for things
so I showed up earlier before anyone was
there and as I pulled in West Craven
pulled into the parking spot next to me
and he got out of the car and I was like
I gotta chase him down so so I like
chased after him and I was like I guess
he was doing a retrospective of his work
at the Egyptian theater which was next
to where the trauma offices were I
chased him down I said oh my god you're
my hero I like I saw the neighbor now
she when I was four and it scared Jesus
out of me and like I did probably want
to make movies now because of you and
blah blah and he's like cool great cool
kid and you like nice to meet you and he
walked away and I went to my I went to
the the the where we were gonna throw
the party and I sat on the step because
I was locked out just like kind of
waiting for everyone to get there and
like ten minutes go by and West craving
comes walking up sits down next to me
he's like let's have a beer and he sat
had a beer with me and just talked about
directing and what it's like to make
stuff and I was like man Last House on
the Left like huh you know and he was
talking me talk to me about all that
stuff and you
talked a little bit about like what it's
like to be a director what it means to
be a director and all that and and when
he got up and left he shook my hand and
there was $300 in his hand which he
donated to the movie - yes see that was
my reaction and so my heart is explode
so yeah mine was - I could not I was
utterly speechless and and it was a
moment for me and and then I kind of
came out of my body a little bit and I
said why like the next the next day I
was in school and they were teaching us
how to turn on a video camera and I was
like I'm not like I this is not where I
am you know like like you guys are
learning stuff that I was doing 10-15
years ago like and so and so that was
really the moment where I stepped away
from school and started like just
focusing on I'm just gonna make stuff
and if if people stopped giving me money
to make stuff I'll go back to college
I'll figure out something but but for
now I'll just start making stuff that
story wins
yeah well everybody knows scream is my
favorite horror movie ever made and it's
my second favorite movie of all time and
wes craven I am so thankful that I had
the opportunity to cross paths with him
I think he is one of the kindest human
beings we had in this industry so he has
a very special place in my heart but you
have said some incredible guardian
angels on yeah I've been I've been both
a mixture of incredibly fortunate and
also it you know it's combination of
three things it's number one I've been
lucky luck is a factor right you like
the fact that I pulled in next door was
crazy right number two I was kind of
fearless like I'm like in a moment where
I could just panic and not say anything
I ran towards him and I said I'm a huge
fan come talk to me about directing and
number three I was always making stuff
so I was always I was always trying to
create opportunities for myself so you
know he had he could come next door and
see that I had you know at a very young
age set up this you know fundraising
thing where you know there was concept
art all over the wall I mean
just see that that that I was taking
myself very seriously at a very young
age and had high expectations myself it
was really those three things that work
together to help me have those
opportunities in those stories jumping
off of those two encounters then
obviously the next step is working with
James because that's one of my favorite
things to see in this industry someone
who has great opportunities for
themselves but also somebody who is a
producer and gives opportunities to
other people too and I think he's doing
that and correct me if I'm wrong but how
did you meet him and what has it been
like with him kind of I guess assuring
you into this opportunity yeah I mean
yeah that's exactly right and and Jay
the truth is that James and I have been
friends for a long time we met maybe 10
12 years ago something like that quite a
while ago and and I mean I guess that
that really is another situation where I
you know you
I met someone at a party and and it was
James and I was like wow I'm a really
big fan of Donald I'm a really big fan
of Luther and you're cool you're a cool
person you're you're nice you're caring
you're a cool person and and and and so
I liked him and and we had mutual
friends and and and we got along and so
for a long time we just hang out and
talk about movies and movies we wish we
could make one day and things that you
know like you know he said to me once
and this is totally true because I had
so much trouble like I go I could sit
and talk to a guy like James or
something guy who kind of looks like me
or I feel like I can look at and talk
about music or citizen you know horror
movies something that that that I know
that the two it was like but I go into
an office and I'd see you know a guy in
a suit or something you know an agent or
a movie producer and I'd be a little
intimidated because those guys didn't
look like my friends growing up and
stuff and and he said to me once that
the you know there's a ton of really
great ways to make money and working in
this industry is definitely not one of
them and and if people are working in
this industry it's because they love
movies you know and you will find that
common thread and if you can't find that
common thread then [ __ ] that person you
know what I mean like like like like
that then if you can't connect on that
level then it's probably for a good
reason
you know if they're not here because
they love movies then I don't know why
they're here so so so so and I've always
held on to that and and and I found it
true with James you know we can
immediately connect on a total of four
movies and I think that most people who
love movies who love talking about
movies they can just sit around and talk
about movies and and so we did that for
a long time anyways I'm going off on
tangents and you ascribing this Collider
bubble that we live in where it's just
like a big office full of people who
love talking about movies right yeah
most people out here like like if people
were to come to Los Angeles and like and
like just walk into offices like this it
would feel very not glamorous for them
because it really is right it's really
just a bunch of movie nerds who are
talking about what happened on Game of
Thrones last night like like that that
then that is kind of the some of it you
know and so and so and it's because
we're all so obsessed with cinema and
all of these things that we've been our
lives and given up our lives to come
take a crack at being here and being a
part of all of it so so so yeah so
anyway so James you know he books this
movie called guardians of the galaxy and
suddenly is propelled into this into
this level that you know he's never seen
and and of just you know massive success
which is awesome but it also gave him
opportunities to to make other movies or
help out people like like me and so and
he really liked my first film the hive
which which I made while he was making
guardians and so and so and not only
that but you know I came through for him
on other projects like I I made it I
created like a VR escape room for Belko
and and I made a music video for
guardians and which is delightful yeah
thank you and and so you know and just I
I I'm coming over achiever and I really
like to knock things out of the park so
so I think he had confidence
me from that you know I have so many
questions specifically about jumping
into bright burn now you know we
mentioned this or at least I did a
little before we started recording this
is a challenging film I mean you have
this idea of making you know somewhat of
a superhero movie which is obviously
super hot right now and you think that
gives you a very good shot of wide
appeal and then you take this turn with
it which is I guess I would describe it
as extremely challenging so why go the
riskier route with a story like this
well I mean you know I see what you mean
that it's riskier but at the same time
the worst thing a movie can be at least
in my opinion is just like vanilla you
know it's it's like what is this it's
nothing and and and so and so yeah I
mean we were certainly bold and when we
go dark we go dark you know but like but
you know I felt like you know I knew the
trailer that we were gonna present right
that was at the very dawn of this movie
there was a trailer in my mind that I
you know had talked to the writers about
talked to James about and we'd all kind
of like sunk up around that trailer and
knowing what that would be and knowing
the promise I was gonna make to the
audience I knew I had to like deliver on
that promise I knew we were gonna be
r-rated I knew we were gonna you know be
taking you know superhero tropes and
turning them dark and so I just I felt a
responsibility to deliver on on that as
someone who's not as someone who's not
easily shocked or you know gore doesn't
tend to have much of an effect on me
there are a couple things in this that
definitely got like a cringe and she
called was there yeah thank you thank
you
was there pushback on that I mean how
how fine tune did you have to make the
editing to get an R on some of those
scenes the version you saw was
completely unchanged from the the way I
shot
so like I did know I didn't I I was as
shocked as you where I was totally
expecting to get pushed back from MPAA
because I've heard things like that I
was expecting yet pushback from the
studio but you know I think that part of
it was James really carved out a kind of
protection to me that I typically
wouldn't have and part of it was that we
were we were an independent film
essentially that Sony acquired and so
and so you know III look back and I
don't know totally how we navigated it
but I think that the the real thing is
is that people thought it was cool yeah
that really is what it is is that is
that especially like you know you know
for a while violence seemed to be like I
don't want to see any violence in
anything but then you know Game of
Thrones came around and and it has such
broad appeal and it killed people in
such brutal ways people you really cared
about such like gnarly ways that it was
kind of like wow you know why is there
this stigma like like there there is
like violent there certainly like
violence in this movie you know but but
I also think that like like it's also
you know you're coming to a horror movie
and you're gonna see you know a
superhero turn their powers on people
and so you kind of need to see what that
looks like and what that feels like and
the most visceral and realistic way
possible so so you know it's like no
one's getting tortured it's just it's
just they're just they're losing jumping
off that a little bit just because I
have a feeling that this question might
come up especially for someone who is
let's say a die-hard superhero Superman
fan when they walk away from this I have
a feeling a thought on some folks brains
might be like why do we why do we need
this movie I hate asking that because
I'm like well what's the purpose of your
movie what do you want people to take
from it but why do we need especially in
the climate now where we have Marvel
dominating DC rising again why do we
need this take on this origin story
sure well look I think those are all
they're good they're good family films
and and I'll go see
them and I'll sit in an audience and
they'll be 10 year olds who are cheering
for it and it's it's all it is a there's
a broad appeal to that and it's a lot of
fun but but I wanted to make something
that that there's a section of the
audience that is sitting there in
watching The Avengers that are like what
what would happen if you know Ironman
just went nuts and started you know
punching people in the head with his
iron suit you know like now I'm kind of
picturing and making like a shared
darker universe and you tackle all of
the heroes I mean you know look like but
but you know they're like so much of
Avengers and the joy of vengers is is a
kind of wish fulfillment of all of us
like imagining what it would be like to
have all these superheroes fighting
together and and you know and and and so
and so I think that the same thing is
true about this movie I've created which
is that part of the joy of the movie is
is is it's some kind of fun wish
fulfillment of like what if you know
what if they didn't also you know what
of a superhero learned about his powers
but didn't also learn this incredibly
important moral lesson that always kept
him like altruistic and good and would
never hurt anyone with it you know like
what if you know and and and so that I
it's just kind of fun thing I mean
you're right like we live in a time
where super heroes have dominated every
aspect of pop culture I feel like I can
see the like CNN you know
2010's you know docu-series about this
time and the episode on superheroes and
how it swallowed everything and so and
so I'm naturally like a counterculture
kind of guy like I kind of like to you
know [ __ ] with whatever is like popular
and and and so and so I don't know it
just kind of made sense and it seemed
like like I don't know the only compass
I have is like I hate you know I start
to think of ideas and it's like what I
will see that would 16 year old me see
that would you know yeah I would think
it was cool so
that's kind of what got me excited about
it as you describe it it also feels like
now is the perfect time for something
like this because you almost get the
added benefit of all of us being steeped
in it and kind of holding your film up
to that version of it that we're so used
to it makes it makes it even more tense
and stressful because I feel like I'm
naturally inclined to look at your make
your main character and say well why
can't you do it like this just like they
and it's frustrating it it adds it's the
suspense of it all well in audiences I'm
a shorthand for how these are supposed
to work now so you can you can play off
those expectations really easily because
everybody speaks superhero fluently yeah
yeah there's a couple moments in the
movie where I or I really definitely
tried to lean in to that where I tried
there's a couple moments really where
he's he's kind of figuring out that he
has powers and like he's having that
moment that you know Peter Parker would
have or something where where he he's
really like oh I have to go you know I
have to go stop some burglaries but you
know instead you know Brandon goes and
raises some hell and and like but those
scenes are really interesting because
and they were fun for me to make because
they kind of feel like that like you
feel the momentum of oh I'm putting all
the pieces together and about to go be
the thing I'm gonna become for the first
time but it it like feels wrong because
you know he's gonna go do really bad
things and and yeah it's this really fun
weird thing that happens I don't know I
I'm glad you guys liked it I can also
see people being disturbed by it but
it's a horror movie you know like you're
gonna engender some hot takes yeah I'm
sure you're aware of that
yeah I'm sure a hundred percent like you
know I you know you know I remember
going to see unbreakable and I'm break
one of my favorite comic book movies of
all time and and I walked out of the
theater thinking I just saw a
masterpiece and my friends were like
that sucked
uh-huh and and you know we argued like
crazy over it you know I think I think
time has proven that like it's a really
great movie and but but but but
I'm not saying that that will
necessarily happen in my movie I'm not
definitely not comparing it's
unbreakable
they're very different movies and all
that but but I do think that there is
something similar in that and that I
think people will come out of it was
strong and painting can you talk a
little bit about Brandon's suit design
because that is just like a pitch
perfect way to even just like isolate it
to marketing we're kind of like catches
your eye and you never forget it did
that go through many iterations before
you settled on that oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah my wife who designed the costume
for this she did all the costumes but
she I've worked with her on I've worked
with over 10 years or something I met
her on a music video a long time ago and
and and we just worked together on
everything since then and she did a
really incredible job and I yeah I went
to her and I said okay this is gonna be
a small ask but like so I want you to
create like the definitive superhero
horror you know
costume that can you know sit on a shelf
of toys next to Freddy Krueger and
Leatherface and and and and Michael
Myers and you know all these all these
icons and and be distinct and be its own
thing and also be scary and also be
something that can be a Halloween
costume and also you know it's just like
the needle she had to thread and and and
she did really an incredible job like
she she nailed it
that costume it's just that the fan art
and stuff that it's inspire does oh yeah
you guys did the the poster competition
right I love seeing movies do that yeah
you know but the the truth of them the
funny thing about it was it wasn't it
wasn't from us it was that we posted the
trailer and suddenly all this fan art
started popping up and so we were like
what are we gonna do with those fan art
we have to do something people are like
reacting this movie in a way that you
know I guess doesn't really happen so
let's create an opportunity and so I
think Sony started putting out this
poster contest and like yeah we got like
I think over a thousand submissions I
mean we got so many so many and so many
that are so good you know I don't know
how they they picked
couple winners because there was a lot
of really good ones it's a solid
assortment looking at it earlier yeah
but but but yes so anyways yeah autumn
did a really incredible job I mean you
know I she we didn't do it the
traditional way because you know James
has had the experience before where you
get these amazing concept artists and
and they they draw something on paper
and you go wow that looks incredible and
then when it's fabricated and real it
and it falls flat it's nothing because
you know the translation of how things
work in reality - in art it doesn't
always translate it's not one-to-one so
so so using that wisdom we we just kind
of employed autumn to just start making
masks and and you know I found a couple
references of like like vintage vintage
photos of children wearing like old like
superhero costumes that looks like their
parents made for them like for five
bucks or something you know that are
super creepy and then and then there was
this there was this like weird vintage
bathing suit that like it was like some
weird [ __ ] that they thought someone
would ever wear but no way no one was
ever gonna wear it was like it was like
to protect you from the Sun and it was
like this weird mask and it kind of had
like this Cape thing it's like floral -
it's and it's a nightmare and and so it
was so so you know I sent those pictures
to autumn and and and and she just
started like I mean there's a photo that
she has which is amazing I keep telling
her she's got posted it's like her like
her office was about this size and it's
her and there's a wall that big and on
every inch of the wall is a different
iteration of the mask it's just covered
with different masks and all the
different ways that she did it with
different materials and different eye
holes and different mouths and I mean
it's it's pretty amazing
yes please convince her to post I'm
I'm sure she will with all of the crazy
set pieces you have in this movie I'm
curious was there any time on set where
you were busy doing something like that
you thought to yourself in the moment on
set this is never gonna work this is
crazy and then you put it together in
the editing room and it works
beautifully
yeah I mean all the time I mean I think
you're constantly there's constantly
moments here and there where you're like
is that a thing is that not a thing I
mean you you know I try to shoot in a
way because I've always until until now
I've had like no budgets I mean this
movie was in a big-budget movie but but
but before this movie my budgets were
much smaller you know and and so I've
always sort of filmed in a strategic way
where I build in like opportunities to
abort you know certain moments are
certain gags that didn't pay off because
I've been stuck in situations where
something looks terrible and I have no
way out of it so so I've always shot
with like redundancy basically like like
okay so we're like over covering and
stuff because it just kind of came up in
an indie way but but yeah yeah III
certainly had a couple moments where I
was concerned with you know how things
looked and and how and how things worked
and and and you know but you know that
something you learn like as directors
you start to mature I say that is I've
only made two movies but but I've done a
lot of music videos and Anna Anna and
hope this feels like part of the process
of maturing is we start shooting you get
to a scene a take that feels really good
you know and everyone gets excited on
set and the producers get excited and
and and your first instinct to still
like do it again and again and again
because it keeps feeling good and you're
like alright let's do another take of
that yeah and everyone's happy and and
and and and then you get to a scene
that's not working it doesn't feel as
good and your instinct is to like okay
we got it let's move on let's get back
to feeling good and and the truth is is
that
you should really do the opposite like
once once something feels good you're
done move on you got it you know and and
when something socks are isn't feeling
rights stay there until it does and
that's I think the single hardest thing
for for early directors to do is when
something isn't working to just say out
loud it isn't working we got to figure
it out because it bums everyone out
everyone starts to panic
everyone gets concerned you know but you
have to just have the confidence to know
that this is part of the process not
everything is going to work out the gate
you got to figure it out it's okay like
you know you know as I mean just tell me
to shut up at some point but but you
know as a director that light that like
moment to moment people are gonna think
like you're stupid or you've made a
mistake or that was dumb that didn't
work you know but but you know because
sometimes you shoot things and you're
like okay that looks dumb as hell right
now but I know it's a piece I need for
the Edit that will look good later or
once the visual effect is in there it'll
look good once they're sound and so you
have to like let go of in the moment
people thinking this is stupid or this
doesn't look right or whatever because
in the in the end basically the movie
works and everyone thinks you're a
genius or it doesn't every thinks you're
an idiot and that's just basically what
being a director the life being a
director is you know before we yeah well
I want to ask the question that the
question okay is it you always ask well
that's turned into two things yeah all
right well I'll ask one okay we like to
ask our guests and I'm particularly
excited for your answers since you are
very invested in horror and clearly as
your history what is sort of just what
you've been seeing whether it's a book
video game movie TV show in the genre
recently that's really had you excited
oh good question I mean I think that
Bioshock is just like the greatest
narrative experience ever I think that
it was like a masterpiece I think of it
as like the Citizen Kane of video games
like like it's the first time I really
felt like there was a director's vision
then it wasn't led by coding he was led
by like an artist
who wanted to tell this story I'm sure
it's happened before but something about
that just it all kind of came together
thematically there's a it's a good
question you know there's a lot of
there's a lot of cool stuff I'm look my
you know my buddies working on Annabelle
comes home right now and I'm incredibly
excited to see that movie I still
haven't seen it and I know what he's
capable of and I know that movie's going
to be amazing
yeah I you know I really like the stuff
that that that James Wan has been kind
of creating over there and yeah and and
and and that movie really opened the
door for for me you know there was a
whole era in which you couldn't couldn't
make it r-rated horror movie because no
one believed there was an audience for
it right and those conjuring movies and
you know yeah I mean the box office is
absolutely nuts from conjuring to the
first it movie the nun yeah breaking
records with our ratings and so that's
how a movie like ours can exist is is
you go hey man those movies are rated R
if you want to be a horror movie that
makes a ton of money I guess we got to
be rated R so many James's yeah yeah but
yeah you know yeah so it's funny how how
well that works you know but but you
know that sort of sort of the
interesting thing about the industry you
know is you know they they shot on
anamorphic lenses they shot two four Oh
and so I can always say hey like you
know the conjuring did it look at all
the money they made you know like we got
to follow the model of the conjuring so
we should definitely shoot anamorphic
shoot on anamorphic lenses because
they're you know they're more
complicated but they're so much prettier
and and and you know stuff like that so
so
yeah that stuff's really cool and yeah
the other pressing question that we sent
my ask our cast and some I don't you
have any pets oh yes I do oh by the way
also I've another friend of mine I don't
know if you know Jeremy so later buddy
Exorcist which was really cool which I
loved Dan might enjoy that show and he's
always working on really cool things I
won't say anything he's working on
because I don't know what is allowed to
but but he's he's a person in horror to
watch he's awesome
[Music]
and then what was the question you asked
that's the burning question do you have
any pets oh yeah yeah yeah I have I do I
have I have two two dogs I really live
with three dogs but but but two of them
are mine well one of them is really mine
one of them is my wife's and this is are
both kind of mine but but there is
certainly that feeling that like this
guy right here is mine that one's your
loyalties are their names
my dog is named Nietzsche and of course
and and and her dog is hi Z and yeah and
then the other dog lives in her house
named kaboom like we can thank Tony Todd
for that question yes Tony Todd Tony
Tony charge and Candyman yeah is a huge
cat lover
Oh is he yeah and it was one of the most
pleasant surprises ever yeah yeah yeah
yeah I uh
yeah I love my dog a lot and the hearted
literally the hardest thing about making
the movie was being away from him for
fun cuz I never been away from him for
that that's way too long I just said two
weeks away from my animals and yeah yeah
yeah and he's he's you know he's not
young so so that makes it harder and
scarier and I wanted to bring him but
but Menino you know if if it was a
bigger budget movie with more support
and more
we were still you know it was still a
down-and-dirty you know I've lived in a
hotel room for four months so it just
wasn't the right place you get to the
point where you're just stopping people
on the street like can I please put your
dog every time someone's like yes I'm
getting the elevator with the dog or
something because I guess was a pet
friendly hotel or something and they
were someone come in like all of it
because you like it was me my wife and
and Mike Dee the cinematographer we all
left dogs behind that we loved and so
and we all kind of like work well autumn
and I were in a room but then Mike was
in the room next door to us so we go up
the elevator together at that day there
was a dog that we would all just be like
oh my god it might be your lucky day
when we walk out of this room there
might be a puppy in the office at night
we do have to wrap this up and the
reason that this is a shorter hour of a
shorter hour I guess a shorter episode
of the witching hour which isn't really
an hour is because we are gonna do a
separate video with you all about the
end of bright burn don't worry
this episode is coming out now and
obviously it was spoiler free but the
next time you come back from having seen
bright burn you are gonna get a spoiler
heavy discussion from the three of us so
don't forget to look out for that but
for now Hayley work and everyone find
you on the internet and find me on
Twitter at Hayley Fauchon on instagram
at haystack mcgroove e and i'm at p
Nemiroff on twitter and instagram
do you have social medias or other
things you'd like to plug yeah I only do
Instagram but I'm just David you're an
esky my name good luck and that's it so
go check that out guys and of course
check out bright burn in theaters May
24th seriously go give that movie a lot
and then come back and message us hit
the comments section and tell us what
you guys think thank you guys so much
for watching and listening
this episode you have officially
survived the witching hour